Kylie Jenner turned 20 on Thursday and  of course her family and friends went  all out for her birthday I'm having so  much fun  [Music]  keilly rang in her bday with an epic  surprise party Wednesday night after  leaving her rumoured boyfriend Travis  Scott's concert earlier that evening she  walked into a room filled with her loved  ones including her rapper beau mom Kris  Jenner and her sisters Kim Khloe and  Kendall  it looks like Khloe's man  Tristan Thompson enjoyed her loca look  for the bash Kim posted this funny shot  of him checking out his lady but the  best part of Kylie's surprise soiree was  the one-of-a-kind party decor that's an  ice sculpture made in the shape of Kyle  isms hourglass figure then there's her  bestie jordan woods posing with her  custom bday cake featuring a hilarious  pic of the lip kit creator with her  tongue out in true emoji style  [Music]  you